hello everyone this next game was played
in 1960 between Boris Spassky and David
Bronstein a lot of people have asked me
in the comments if I would show a King's
gambit game so I decided to show this
one this is probably one of my favourite
games played in the Kings gambit and if
you're wondering about the title of the
video well we'll get to that part after
I show you the game so Boris Spassky is
white and he plays efore we have E 5 by
brunch time and F for the King's gambit
brunch and accepts the gambit and we
have Knight to f3 d5e capture some v 5
and Bishop to d6 we have Knight to c3 by
Spassky when I say 7 and now b4 broad
sand castles we have Bishop to d3 and
now Knight to d7 and Spassky castles and
in this position well you can see that
the brush lines nights are pretty poorly
placed here they're kind of kind of
kwanzaa here and the brush line should
have probably went for something like
Knight to f6 and try and develop this
LightSquared bishop but rushed and
played h6 and this isn't a bad move this
is an OK move but what he finds a really
good idea which which activates his game
a lot he plays a temporary pawn
sacrifice and goes for 94 so brush and
accepts the pawn he plays an IP after
Sun d5 and now it's pasta pushes c4 and
if you look at this position brush and
can play something like Knight to f6 or
937 cramping T's pieces again well not
nice to e7 because you will get c5 but
it's for the Knights to f6 then possible
simply capture the dark square bishop
and with a bishop pair in this kind of
position you will be a lot better so run
Stein place Knights to e3
as far as spotty captures it Bishop
captures on e3 we have F captures on II
III and now pushes c5 we have Bishop to
e7 and now Bishop to C 2 and this is an
attacking move as it prepares a queen to
d3 so we have a rook to e8 by Bronstein
and now Queen to d3 and here a spark is
threatening all kind of all sorts of
discoveries with tonight to g5 Knight to
d6 and going for that h7 square with 28
mate so with a brush and tries eetu if
you would like he would like the queen
to capture the pawn just you know to get
some breeding space here and in this
position spot he plays one of the one of
the greatest positional sacrifices he
plays Knight to d6 and if you look at
this position well Bronstein can
captured orokin f1 he can also capture
the night on v6 well not really because
the Queen takes h7 check is coming so
brony spectra is a nice to f8 and here
spot C plays Knight captures on f7
bryceton captures the rook on f1 which
checks rook captures on f1 and well to
tell you the first this is the kind of
an equal position and engine could
probably defend this but not not a
player like Bronston even though he was
an extremely strong player so we have
Bishop to f5 bursts and decides to give
back a piece just to improve his
position and try and exchange Queens so
Sparkie captures the bishop for Queen
captures on at five and Bronstein plays
Queen to d7 going for the Queen exchange
but flutter plays Queen to f4 and now if
you look at this position he does have a
very nice threat here on the earth file
and this bishop is slicing very nicely
all the way to 87 and brush and tries
Bishop to f6 so we have a nice to e5 and
well again Bernstein doesn't want to
capture the night because after this
Knight captures here if you will have
all sorts of checks again with the
Knight to g6 and
Quinta Defour it will be very unpleasant
so brush and tries Queen to e7 and not
spot skew really continues the attack
place Bishop to b3 and in this position
well there really isn't much that
brushing can do but he tries the bishop
captures any v and now we have Knight
captures on e5 and Bronston doesn't want
to go with a scheme to h8 because he
doesn't want to allow a nice step 7
check so he plays a king 287
and in this position spot to place
Quinta efore checking the king and well
after spot he played the smooth burns
and resigned because if he moves the
king like for example let's say I don't
know King to h8 or something then this
is completely over
it's actually amazing for you would get
rook captures a net face with check and
after this rook is captured leader by
the Queen let's say Queen captures on f8
you would get nice to g6 check into h7
Knight captures and I face was check
King to HS and queen to h7 mate
so yeah a very nice game by Spassky and
a very very attractive idea sacrificing
that point even temporarily to get to
gain some kind of initiative after he
saw that Bronson's Knights were poorly
placed and that well he was far better
in development now the reason why I said
that the spot his game goes to Hollywood
is a I don't know if you've seen the
movie James Bond Specter and I'm not I'm
not really going to go into the details
but this game is actually feature
featured in the film and well two guys
are playing chess and well this is the
position on the board let me just go
back a couple of moves yeah and this is
the position on the board the only thing
that's different is the this C pawn and
this D point because the the director of
the film thought that chess games had
copyright and he thought that he
couldn't play the exact same position
that was in this game into the movie so
he removed the pawns but everything else
and the winning combination is the same
so yeah that's it I hope you enjoyed
this game very nice game and Boris
Spassky did use the King's gambit quite
a lot he even defeated defeated Bobby
Fischer once using the King's gambit it
was in the first game they ever played
say I hope you enjoyed it and as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
and I'll see you soon thanks for
watching